خشيه كبيره يشعر بها مستخدم تويتر في
بريطانيا بعد الاضطرابات التي شهدتها
المنصه الاجتماعيه اثر استحواذ ال الماسك
عليها فما لبث ان استلم ماسك شؤون الشركه
حتى بدا بتغييره جذريا لاسباب الاقتصاديه
واخرى سياسيه وصفها البعض بانها اتخذت
بسرعه مبالغ فيها في ما وصف خبراء ماسك
بانه لا يعرف ماذا يقوم به وقد برزت الى
الواجهه منصه مثل هايب وغيرها كخيار من
دون ان تثبت كفاءتها حتى ساعه في الحلول
محلات تويتر
واستبدالها يجب ان يحصل ذلك بشكل تلقائي
اذ لن يقرر العالم كله مره واحده الانتقال
الى منصه جديده ولهذا السبب اعتقد انه من
الصعب استبداله بسهوله اعتقد فعليا ان
تويتر هو الخيار الوحيد الذي لدينا
والى جانب التغريدات المثيره للجدل التي
ينشرها ماسك بين الحين والاخر وتسريح
عشرات الموظفين من مكاتب الشركه حول
العالم او موجه الاغلاقات التي طالت
مكاتبهم بشكل مؤقت او دائم احيانا وفرض
رسوم على مستخدمي الاشاره الزرقاء وقراري
ماسك باعاده شخصيات مثيره للجدل مثل ترامب
وكانيوست كل هذه الاسباب ربما تكون دفعت
العديده الى البحث عن منصه تواصل بديله او
الى تقليص الوقت الذي يقدمه على منصه امم
اوروبا
مثل التعليقات المعاديه للساميه او
العنصريه التي سيتاح للناس الان التحدث
بها
رئيس تويتر على ماسك الاهتمام بموظفيه هو
لا يقوم بذلك الان بعد تسريح العديد كما
ان اتاحه الفرصه لدونالد ترامب للعوده الى
المنصه لها بعد خطير بسبب الاخبار الزائفه
مكان العمل
والقد لج
ا البحث عن حمايه من اساليب ماسك في
معامله الموظفين
مكاتب تويتر في لندن في هذه البنايه هنا
شهدت اغلاقات مؤقته هي الاخرى بعد استلام
ماسك للشركه وهو الذي اتخذ عده اجراءات
زادت من التكهنات بان منصه تويتر
اما من الناحيه الاقتصاديه او من ناحيه
الوظيفه الاخلاقيه والمهنيه
عبد الحق العربي